if I had a university to direct and in
some ways I hope wanted to have my own
foundation where I will teach people
things there will be a course in
mistakes in the sense that we discard
mistakes we brush them aside we in a non
creative way mistakes are our best
teachers when I make a mistake there is
two things
parallel happening in my head in my
heart unconsciously I I try to find the
why of the situation and very
consciously I observe what happened or
you know recall what happens and find
the sometime the myriads of details that
I didn't pay attention to or sometimes
it's as simple as I was not focusing
enough you know if I cut a piece of wood
with the sole and not really focus and
the blade of the soul jumps and you know
and start scratching my finger what what
a great lesson because I maybe didn't
observe how the fibers of the wood where
maybe I didn't sharpened so correctly
maybe I was saying hello to a friend
passing by instead of concentrating on
on a curve you know the width of the
blade and it's very easy it's very easy
to observe a mistake and tend to back
track and to find out what were the
causes of that so I am always a very
interested it's like a solving problem
you know it's it's interesting for me to
investigate what went wrong
you